at a time when the markets are giving
many investors a rough ride warren
buffett is buying the dip
the billionaire investor is adding
several new major positions to his
portfolio as his investing conglomerate
berkshire hathaway deployed more than 51
billion dollars into stocks during the
first quarter of 2022 this is
berkshire's biggest quarterly spending
spree in recent history among the major
purchases were 55 million shares of
citigroup worth about 2.6 billion
dollars and 69 million shares of
paramount global worth around 1.9
billion dollars berkshire also made
sizable purchases in two energy
companies chevron and occidental
petroleum legacy tech company hp and
video game company activision blizzard
the total shares held by berkshire for
those companies are now roughly 159
million for chevron worth about 27
billion dollars 143 million for
occidental worth about 10 billion
121 million hp shares worth over 4
billion dollars and 64 million shares of
activision worth about 5 billion
berkshire also notably exited 2 large
stakes in the first quarter of 2022
buffett sold all of his shares in wells
fargo which had previously been a top
holding and part of his portfolio since
1989. he also sold nearly all of his 8
billion stake in telecom giant verizon
holding just 1.4 million shares at the
end of march way down from the more than
150 million shares he owned at the end
of december 2021 buffett remains a top
contender on the forbes list being the
fifth richest person in the world with a
net worth of about 113 billion dollars
[Music]